a judge in texas has put a stop
temporarily to the policy of united
airlines that would have put their
unvaccinated employees on unpaid leave
now
this gives the judge time to rule the
hearings begin on wednesday
and the the policy is on hold until
october 26th uh that will give the judge
the time to reach his decision uh now at
this point uh the lawsuit was brought
because six employees of united airlines
said that the vaccine mandate was a
violation of their rights and filed in
court
this is a class action brought to remedy
united's pattern of discrimination
against employees who requested
religious or medical accommodations from
united's mandate that its employees
received the covert 19 vaccine now other
airlines have had similar policies
requiring employees to be vaccinated by
december american airlines and southwest
airlines and after southwest airlines
filed in court
about possibly you know trying to get
these restrictions overturned arguing
they're not inconsistent with u.s labor
laws there were thousands of flights
that were canceled around the country
causing a little bit of panic at the
airports
[Music]
i've never been
in favor of corporations imposing that
kind of a mandate executive order from
president biden mandates that all
federal employees and then all federal
contractors have to have a mandate and a
vaccine in place by december the 8th so
we're working through that
[Music]
now another workplace that has
apparently been affected by this is the
white house however the white house
denies rumors that some staff were
not coming to work in protest of the
vaccine mandate this is what the white
house spokesperson said when confronted
with these rumors implementing these
mandates creates certainty it reduces uh
the number of people who are out of work
sick
and worse and that is good ultimately
for businesses it's good for the economy
i know there was a little hubbub over
the course of the last few days about
southwest airlines we now know that some
of those claims were absolutely false
and actually the issues were
completely unrelated to vaccine mandates
now boeing which is a major aerospace
corporation in the united states has
moved to comply with biden's orders
regarding federally contracted
corporations and their vaccination
policies however there's been quite a
bit of resistance throughout the united
states uh texas has gone as far as
banning vaccine
requirements uh so at this point these
vaccine mandates we're seeing from the
biden administration and for major
companies airlines etc are causing quite
a bit of division in the country
americans don't see eye to eye on this
question
you